the jurogan experience and it's not just
china and this is the theory but the
thing about the lab league and why i
actually want to de-culture
you you had josh rogan on and yeah he is
really good that guy's amazing what he
what he expertly shows is if this is
true the lab leak hypothesis is true yes
the chinese covered up guess what the
chinese are liars and they covered up
sars and they've covered up basically
everything that's come out of their
country for the last like 30 years
that's not a shocker the shocker is dr
anthony fauci
2017 reverses the ban on gain of
function research directs this funding
to eco health alliance
dr peter dazak who then gives it to the
wuhan institute of virology for the
study of novel
bat coronaviruses and then when the
pandemic turns around
we take dr peter dazzak as the only
american
to join the world health organization's
investigation team
into whether coronavirus leaked from a
lab and on 60 minutes
i forget who was interviewing him she
goes well wait so
do how did you verify it did you just
ask them and he goes well what else can
we do because he's also half british
and that's how he goes well uh what else
can we do
oh uh we could read emails we could also
see that
peter dazzak as of two days ago has been
caught lying he said
there were no live bats inside
of the wuhan institute of virology sky
news australia
just revealed 2017 video that bats were
present inside the wuhan survivorology
and the deputy director says before this
china had no experience in bsl4
labyrinth that's the highest level
safety for a laboratory
but we have been here and i i don't
forget i don't want to
misquote him but he said something along
the lines of creating
new viruses synthesizing new viruses and
what fauchi and
dr she who's the head of the wuhan
institute of virology they're playing
[ __ ] games
fauci and rand paul when rand paul was
pressing him he was like we did not
fund gain of function research
he's trying to define it as explicitly
what he
what is on the record of him funding dr
xi is the same thing
we were not doing gain of function
research
this is actually this is amazing i don't
know if you caught she did
an email interview with the new york
times which was mostly i mean it was
just you know
the standard like state party line from
china
but they asked her about gain of
function research and
i'm sure your listeners mostly know know
that gain of function research is
basically modifying these
to see what how can we make these
pathogens more
dangerous right and it's very it's in
and of itself very dangerous because
these things do leak from labs
um relatively routinely and she says we
were not doing gain a function research
because what we were doing
wasn't making it more virulent or
dangerous
it was seeing if it could jump from
species to species
i'm sorry isn't that like the definition
of making it more dangerous for us
seeing if you can make it
jump into our species like that seems
like that's pretty dangerous
so they're trying to play this game it's
not technically gained how does fouchy
get away
with standing there under oath and
saying media
right it's all media pressure which is
he's the god it's the
it's the anti-trump derangement syndrome
right fauci was
put up as like the anti-trump guy and he
became this
liberal icon i mean there are these
signs in washington
d.c of people's yards i don't know if
you have them here but
it's literally his face on a sign and
like
thank you dr fauci jesus this is what
we're dealing with joe
this is what we're dealing with those
people too right
and again no one is above reproach every
human being
is flawed and especially when you're in
that kind of position of power and you
have certain incentives like you have to
ask
questions about these things but there
was another element too
and this was frankly in an ingenious
play by
the media and the scientific community
is not only was it oh trump and his band
of wackos
are the ones that are promoting this
theory but also that
this theory is somehow racist and the
moment that the lab leak theory was
pegged as
racist that's when it really became
toxic for
anyone in the mainstream to ask
questions about because you don't want
to be pegged as like oh well you're just
pursuing this racist conspiracy theory
and my thought has always been from the
beginning like first of all
we just need the answer like neutrally
to look at
what actually happened here but second
of all if we're playing them
which is more racist game it seemed way
worse to me when people were like oh
chinese people eat bats and that's
disgusting and they're so weird and
that's how we all got this pandemic
that seemed to me way more problematic
than the idea that a lab that by the way
the usa
is funding that something leaked
accidentally from that lab
so that was really the thing that put
this all off the table was this
strategic
weaponization of you know what is a very
real problem of
alleging racism it's the scientific
community teamed up with
well basically they got the luckiest
[ __ ] break of their lives that trump
was president
because and they made it so that it was
racist to question even recently the
lead new york times reporter on covet
tweeted and then deleted are we ever
going
someday we will acknowledge the racist
origins of the lab league theory new
york times reporter
who's in charge of cobit right this is
still in their in their brains they have
brain worms
because of trump and i was telling
crystal because of trump
35 of this popular you could have
smoking gun proof their lab leak theory
was true
35 of the population hardcore democrats
who watch msnbc they'll never believe
it they'll always say that it's racist
and here's the problem
which this is the same problem with all
trump stuff if gaynor if this is true
we should be having a national
conversation around gain of function
research we should have a wuhan
commission
around gain of functional research
instead they want to do a january 6
commission
in order to reconstruct the events of a
day where we all [ __ ] know what
happened okay
it's over we know i'm not saying it
wasn't terrible but that is not
what the driving conference what is it
[ __ ] it's june 15th why are we still
talking
about gain about january 6. we should be
talking right now
did u.s government funds explicitly
directed towards
novel coronavirus research which led to
the worst pandemic in a century and cost
the global economy
trillions of dollars and as josh is the
first one to point out
the response from the scientific
community has been we need more gain of
function research
1.2 billion dollars to the global virum
project
and so once again the scientific
community wanted all of this covered up
they teamed up with the media
to protect their funding resources
because what people forget
fauci is actually the king of funding
the national institute of infectious
disease i believe that's with nid that's
what he's
in charge of they are the primary
funding authority
for huge amounts of the scientific
community we had dr brett weinstein on
our show and he was explaining this to
us
which is that if you're inside of that
research system
you need access to those dollars to keep
your lab afloat
like for my dad is a professor at texas
a m and so i know a little bit about
funding and like
the way that you keep your tenure
positions in a lot of these universities
is you have to like continually bring
funding in so both my parents are
professors there
and so like a lot of the professorial
game is getting money from granting
institutions
now in the science community it's from
the national science foundation it's
from the national institute or whatever
fauci
is the head of the national institute of
health they have to keep the dollars
flowing
so if you admit this is gain of function
research you start asking questions
nih and fauci can [ __ ] cut you off
like this is a whole
business it's a multi-billion dollar i
mean it's an
industry because it's about research and
look the core theme of our show is like
follow the money right so
follow the money where's the money lead
at least fauci peter dazzak and it's
like
look i don't want to sound crazy but
this is basically like a global
conspiracy in terms of
the chinese government it's a total
cover-up of the chinese government the
us government
the guy who was on the [ __ ] tv and we
were all supposed to trust this entire
time
and it turns out like he's the guy who
reversed the ban
in the first place in order to take
advantage of the chaos under trump
and i know it's so complicated and
regular people
this is what bothers me most about the
mainstream media people want to live
their lives and they want answers
and increasingly they know they are
being lied to but they do not have the
time because it's our job in order to
you know explain all this about peter
dazak and the
world health organization what is gain
and function research how washington
actually works
the global funding structures etc people
are being lied to
they have been completely lied to on the
story i think i do think this is the
biggest failure since iraq wmd i think
this is wmd 2.0 catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience